breaking our dependence on China and
holding its communist government
accountable for its mishandling and
deception in the early days of the
coronavirus joining me now to discuss
that and more Republican senator from
the great state of Texas Ted Cruz good
evening senator judge good evening good
to be with you all right senator it's my
understanding that in addition to
several bills that have already been
proposed in Congress that you were
coming at this dealing with China from a
lot of different directions you have
several bills that you're about to
submit on Tuesday in Congress or and
tell us what you're where you're coming
from them what you're what you're
dealing with
well absolutely China is in my judgment
the single greatest geopolitical threat
the United States faces over the next
century they engage in espionage they
engage in censorship they engage in
torture and murder of their own citizens
they cover up free speech and you know
so I've got three bills that I'm
introducing this coming week one is
focused on the corona virus cover-up and
it imposes strict sanctions on Chinese
government officials who covered up this
pandemic they are directly responsible
for this pandemic that has killed over
240,000 people worldwide because the
heroic physician whistleblowers that
tried to blow the whistle tried to stop
this at the outset the Chinese communist
government came down on them punished
them silenced them and you know we used
to think of their suppression of speech
as a human rights issue we now it is
clear to everyone this is a national
security issue and this is a public
health issue
secondly when it comes to propaganda
I've entered I'm introducing legislation
called the script act that is focused on
Hollywood Hollywood far too often let's
China the Chinese communist government
censor American films and so the script
Act says that we're not going to allow
the Pentagon to cooperate with movie
makers to let them use ships and jet
airplanes and equipment if
they are going to allow the Chinese
government to censor it and so it uses
the power of government to stop Chinese
censorship through Hollywood all right
so when you say the Pentagon you they
are China when they're when movies are
being made the Pentagon is cysts by
allowing them to use their property give
us an example give us an example of a
movie but there are lots and lots of
examples there been over a thousand
movies you look at something like I'll
give you a great example a movie coming
out later this year which is top guns to
the sequel to top gun you know you think
about topic on it may have ended up
being the greatest Navy Recruiting film
ever filmed you know you got maverick
flying in jets everyone you know you
young boys and girl girls wanted to be
fighter pilots like that well the new
Top Gun to the Chinese government took
issue with the fact that Mavericks
jacket the back of it had a flag a
Japanese flag and a Taiwanese flag and
and so the movie maker has censored them
it has changed the jackets and think
about it for a second judge what we're
saying is that maverick is scared of the
Chinese Communists that is ridiculous
and and and Hollywood producers who
claim they support the the First
Amendment and a free speech readily let
the Chinese government censor then I'll
give you another example you know the
movie Bohemian Rhapsody just came out
pretty recently the the wonderful biopic
of Freddie Mercury the lead singer of
Queen Mercury the Chinese government
censors objected to a scene in the movie
that that acknowledged that Freddie
Mercury was gay and so they edited the
scene out of the movie and Hollywood
went happily along how on earth do you
tell the story of Freddie Mercury
without acknowledging it was games a big
part of his life and and Hollywood does
this over and over again and so we've
got real levers by saying listen the
government is not going to facilitate
your empowering the Chinese censors well
you know what's amazing senator is
Hollywood is so willing to do that for
the Chinese but you know in the end
they're willing to
you know to criticize those of us who
stand up for the First Amendment in this
country anyway senator Ted Cruz thanks
so much for being with us and sharing
your that information with us